c'est l'un des derniers alliés de la
Russie en Europe la Biélorussie
d'Alexandre lucachenko depuis le début
de la guerre en Ukraine en février 2022
le pays soutient les actions de Moscou
et surtout sert de base arrière au
soldatus pour certaines de leurs
attaques alors que depuis plusieurs mois
les exercices militaires conjoint entre
ces deux nations ce succèdent la Russie
a décidé d'envoyer des soldats en
Biélorussie afin de superviser
l'entraînement des forces armées du pays
qui seraient mal en point nous vous
proposons dans ce nouvel épisode de
facture de faire un point sur cette
armée biélorus pour savoir si oui ou non
elle est capable d'épauler militairement
le Kremlin
l'armée biélorus reste modeste son
budget est estimé à 800 millions de
dollars et représenterait seulement 1,2
% de son PIB ces forces terrestres
disposent de 682 temps des T80 et T72
soviétiques 1821 véhicules de transport
d'infanterie et 1041 pièces d'artillerie
son aviation ne serait constituée que de
199 appareils dont 34 avions de chasse
68 hélicoptères et 67 avions d'attaque
enfin elle ne possède aucune marine
militaire il s'agit également d'une
armée majoritairement composée de
conscrits le service militaire national
est obligatoire et concerne les jeunes
hommes âgés de 18 à 27 ans pour une
durée de 12 à 18 mois elle est donc
inexpérimentée non professionnel et
surtout équipé d'armes soviétiques pour
la plupart vieilles de plus de 30 ans
les rendant donc obsolètes sur un champ
de bataille face à une armée moderne
comme celle que l'Ukraine est en train
de se constituer grâce à l'entraînement
et à la livraison d'armes occidentales
l'armée biélorus faut imaginer que c'est
un peu comme l'armée russe moins
entraîné avec moins d'hommes et qui ne
se serait pas modernisé depuis au moins
une vingtaine d'années donc on est
vraiment sur une armée vieillissante
mais quel avantage de la masse comme
beaucoup d'armées soviétiques
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont des centaines et
des centaines de charpentières en
réalité c'est pas une armée qui est
conçue pour des corps expéditionnaires
c'est-à-dire qu'elle a pas de moyens de
projection elle manque à priori de
véhicule même pour amener les chars si
elle devait se déplacer hors de son
territoire on pense par exemple à une
attaque sur l'Ukraine donc elle est pas
adaptée pour attaquer l'Ukraine donc en
capacité offensive elle représente
vraiment quelque chose qui est tout à
fait infime sa force résiderait-elle
alors dans ses effectifs selon les
chiffres officiels le pays disposerait
de 62000 troupes d'actives et de 344000
troupes de réserves une information a
relativiser cependant car les services
secrets occidentaux estiment que le
nombre réel de combattants prêts au
combat avoisinerait plutôt les 10000
les forces armées biélorusses feraient
donc pas le figures en comparaison de
leurs voisins Ukrainiens il est
également important de considérer la
situation politique de la Biélorussie
elle a un réel impact sur ce que ses
forces armées peuvent ou non se
permettre de faire depuis le soulèvement
insurrectionnel de 2020 à la suite
d'élection truquées et maté d'une main
de fer mins que ne peut se permettre de
relâcher sa vigilance vis-à-vis de la
société civile ces forces de sécurité se
sont avérées incapables de lutter contre
les actes de sabotage des partisans
antilocachenko et l'ont dénombre près de
80 attaques contre les voies ferrées
servant justement à acheminer matériel
et homme à la frontière avec le crâne
affecter des soldats dévoluent jusque là
au maintien de l'ordre à des opérations
de conquête militaires pourraient
s'avérer dangereux pour le pouvoir en
effet en cas de mouvement
révolutionnaire il se retrouverait en
difficulté la question de la
mobilisation poserait également problème
les morts sur le champ de bataille et le
ressentiment de la population face à une
mobilisation d'ampleur pourraient faire
vaciller le régime de lucachenko et ses
soutiens politiques déjà fortement
érodés le pays risquerait alors de
tomber plus dans l'escarcelle de Moscou
la question de la Russie est justement
centrale pour comprendre le rôle de ses
forces armées biélorusses tout d'abord
les deux pays appartiennent à la même
alliance militaire l'OTSC il s'agit de
l'Organisation du Traité de sécurité
collective l'équivalent russe de l'OTAN
il regroupe la Biélorussie la Russie
l'Arménie le Kazakhstan le Kirghizistan
et le Tadjikistan cette alliance sert
principalement à maintenir Moscou comme
force dominante dans la région ce qui
transforme de fait les soldats biélorus
en supplétif de l'armée russe le grand
intérêt de l'armée biélorus c'est de
continuer à faire peser une menace sur
l'Ukraine même si elle est quand même
très très peu de crédible ça impose à
l'Ukraine de maintenir des dizaines et
des dizaines de milliers de soldats et
de matériels dans le Nord face à cette
frontière qui fait des centaines de
kilomètres de long ils ont construit
beaucoup de lignes de défense mais ces
soldats il serait évidemment beaucoup
mieux utilisés s'il pouvait réellement
se battre contre la Russie sur le front
de l'Est dans le Dombasle par exemple
donc pour l'instant
l'armée biélorus même si elle est pas
employée elle a quand même un intérêt
stratégique pour la Russie dans le sens
où ça oblige l'Ukraine à répartir ces
troupes un petit peu partout sur son
territoire durant l'hiver 2022 2023 les
forces armées russes ont acheminées du
matériel lourd vers la frontière entre
la Biélorussie et l'Ukraine via des
lignes de chemin de fer des soldats
aussi le renseignement américain estime
que Moscou y aurait convoyé plus de 20
000 hommes possiblement en prévision
d'opération offensive à l'approche du
printemps c'est même soldats
entraînerait leurs homologues
biélorusses cette idée que la Russie
puisse faire une erreur stratégique en
entraînant son allié biélorus dans une
offensive sur le Nord aujourd'hui ça
paraît quand même très très peu probable
mais il y a eu tellement d'erreurs et
d'incompréhenses stratégiques de la part
de la Russie qu'on peut évidemment rien
d'exclure
mal équipé en sous-effectif dépassé
technologiquement et difficilement
capable de mobiliser des troupes les
forces armées biélorusses semblent en
effet avoir besoin de l'entraînement que
Moscou leur dispense aujourd'hui une
situation qui pourrait être amenée à
changer si le Kremlin réussit son pari
de mettre à niveau les troupes de
lucachingo
[Musique]